marie laure phinéra horth pour le groupe
air des pays
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la fois
guyanaise couvre 8 millions d'hectares
soit 96 % du territoire de la guyane
l'état il a confié 6 millions d'hectares
de son domaine privé au seul office
national des forêts en guyane et nulle
part ailleurs
lodève dispose ainsi de rôle de
conservateur gestionnaire mais aussi
d'opérateurs faisant de ces agents des
juges et partie dans bon nombre de
dossiers en 2015 rapport de la
délégation sénatoriale à l'outre-mer a
émis 30 propositions pour je cite mettre
un terme à une gestion jalouse et
stérile du domaine public et privé de
l'état en outre-mer
ce rapport a proposé une nouvelle
architecture propre à la guyane pour
libérer du foncier d'état au service du
développement local notamment en
accélérant les procédures de cession de
terrains du domaine privé en repoussant
vers l'intérieur des terres les limites
du domaine forestier permanent et en
transférant le foncier libéré à la
collectivité unique de guyane
charge à elle de le rétrocéder aux
communes et aux acteurs économiques
monsieur le ministre l'exploitation du
bois et des produits de la forêt
constitue une filière d'avenir pour la
guyane
mais l'accès à la ressource reste
aujourd'hui encore problématique carlo
nf demeure l'unique fournisseur de bois
pour les professionnels de la première
transformation
l'état semble réticent à laisser une
partie de la maîtrise foncière à la
collectivité territoriales de guyane qui
en cas de rétrocession disposerait d'un
levier permettant de mettre en oeuvre
une véritable politique de développement
économique
et pourtant après les événements de 2017
l'état s'était engagé à transférer deux
cent cinquante mille hectares à la
collectivité territoriales de guyane
ce transfert malheureusement n'a
toujours pas eu lieu il pourrait éviter
certaine crispation au sein de la
population sur des problématiques telles
que la chasse ou leur paille âge légal
c'est pourquoi je souhaite savoir
monsieur le ministre ce que compte faire
le gouvernement pour tenir cet
engagement et aider ainsi au
développement économique de la guyane je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice je vous remercie pour votre
question qui est incroyablement
importante
si la forêt un rôle majeur dans
l'ensemble des écosystèmes
évidemment la forêt guyanaise un rôle
important pour la guyane
probablement pour une grande partie de
l'ensemble du bassin où elle est située
voire à l'échelle mondiale donc c'est un
trésor et en même temps une
responsabilité qui est collégialement de
la nôtre de préserver cette forêt
guyanaise
le deuxième élément c'est que vous
l'avez dit le gouvernement s'est engagé
dans ces transferts alors de mémoire ces
transferts ils vont assez loin parce
qu'il ya quatre cent mille hectares qui
doit être transférée à la population de
250 mille hectares de mes marques et
vous l'avez dit qu'il doit être
transférée aux collectivités et 20 mille
hectares à une affaire ainsi constitué
je suis d'accord avec vous c'est pas
aller assez vite et d'ailleurs je crois
ne pas dire d'erreurs mais je le vérifie
ray vous dirai dans la dernière voie
asap uludag du on a passé un nouvel
amendement permettant d'aller encore
plus vite dans ces transferts à titre
gracieux ce que vous le savez que la
difficulté juridique c'était ce volet à
titre gracieux donc ma réponse elle est
tout simplement au clair il faut mettre
en oeuvre rapidement les engagements que
nous avons pris dans ces transferts je
peux pas être plus clair et je vais y
veiller pour répondre le plus rapidement
possible à votre demande qui est une
demande à la fois légitime mais surtout
nécessaire donc nous nous le ferons et
nous le font rapidement possible merci
madame finir à orthe vous avez trente
deux secondes de pur la réplique
merci monsieur le ministre votre réponse
tout ce que j'ai à dire c'est que
effectivement le peuple guyanais attend
la concrétisation